today on the matt walsh show amid
sky-high inflation the bite
administration wants us to take solace
in the fact that the federal reserve is
more diverse and also gayer than it's
ever been today we'll talk about
diversity and whether it's something
that really is worth celebrating also
republicans are losing their grip on the
midterms why is this happening and how
can the trend be reversed john fetterman
says that voter id is racist because
black people don't know how to get
driver's licenses according to him a
school in wisconsin reintroduces
corporal punishment and the new york
times announces that maternal instinct
is a myth invented by the patriarchy all
of that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're in search of financial peace
of mind make sure you're not wasting
money on high interest rates because
they're only going to get worse as the
fed continues to raise rates it's
important that you act now therefore you
can get a great deal in as little as 10
days by calling american financing get a
free mortgage review from a salary based
mortgage consultant
no pressure no obligation no upfront or
hidden fees just a simple conversation
around custom loans that can fit your
budget better from better rates to
shorter terms even debt consolidation
options you can save up to a thousand
dollars a month with american financing
and uh listen this is something that we
should all be doing because we're all
looking for
ways to save money and we know that we
also cannot rely on uh the powers that
be to fix any of these problems for us
so we have to take initiative and do it
ourselves and if you want to do that
here's what you got to do it's very
simple call 866 569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 just one short phone call
we'll put you on the path to making
everything better for yourself or visit
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmlsconsumeraccess.org
this weekend the ap published the
exciting news headline fed tackles
inflation with its most diverse
leadership ever apparently as the
associated press reports to the great
relief of every ordinary american the
federal reserve has at this moment the
widest array of races genders and
orientations that it's ever had reading
more from the article says there are
more female black and openly gay
officials contributing to the central
bank's interest rate decisions than at
any time in its 109 year history many
are also far less wealthy than the
officials they have replaced over time
economists say a wider range of voices
will deepen the fed's perspective as it
weighs the consequences of raising or
lowering rates it may also help
diversify a profession that historically
hasn't been seen as particularly
welcoming to women and minorities
broadly that's helpful said william
english a former senior economist at the
fed who teaches at the yale school of
management there's evidence that diverse
groups make better decisions
now surely this is a great comfort to
the average american our monetary
policies have led to sky-high inflation
the worst in decades which has made it
difficult for normal people to feed and
clothe themselves and their children
this is a source of enormous stress and
heartache
but at least we can all take solace in
the fact that the people setting up
these disastrous monetary policies
are extremely diverse
indeed there has never been so many gay
people black people and women involved
in not solving a problem
and and that makes it all better i mean
it really does just the other day i was
uh this is true i was at the grocery
store
and i overheard
a conversation between a husband and
wife as they were walking through the
dairy section and the husband was
complaining about how everything was so
expensive and the wife said to him this
is what she said she said
yes i know honey i wish we could afford
food also
but remember that there are lots of gays
at the federal reserve now
and then they just hugged each other and
sobbed
tears of joy
and the husband said you're right our
kids don't need to eat
there have been many exchanges just like
this all over the country
at least that's what we're supposed to
believe
truly we are not far from the point when
prisons will start bragging about the
diversity of their execution teams if
this isn't happening already i don't
know i mean you can imagine
someone leaning down to the man strapped
to the gurney and saying uh we're about
to administer the lethal injection just
thought you should know that the team
overseeing your death is the most
diverse in history the guy with the
needle right there he's actually
bisexual
we also have a trans woman and an
autistic korean here as well so i hope
that makes hope that makes you feel a
little bit better about your painful
death
that's where we're headed
in fact this has been a banner week for
diversity and not just at the federal
reserve on monday
nasa was scheduled to launch the first
voyage of its artemis mission artemis 1
is set to be the first unmanned mission
to the moon in many years eventually at
all if all goes to plan artemis ii
uh will follow a year or two behind and
then around 2025 that's the plan anyway
artemis iii will launch with a manned
crew
who will be the first human beings to
walk on the moon since 1972
and that will be followed by artemis iv
and down the road if all goes again
according to plan this will lead to
manned missions to mars and and beyond
now it all seems quite
exciting as it represents the next phase
of human space exploration uh perhaps
the inauguration of a new age of
discovery that would be pretty great
that's why i find it exciting anyway
but nasa wants us to be excited for
different reasons on the nasa artemis
twitter page
given two sentences to describe the
purpose and goal of the artemis mission
in their in their bio
right so they've got limited space to
just tell people this is what the
mission is all about this is the most
important thing about the mission
this is what they decided to lead with
this is what it says
with artemis nasa will land the first
woman and first person of color on the
moon
take the next giant leap with us
so forget space exploration forget mars
forget the discoveries that'll weight us
out in deep space instead
think about the skin pigment and sex of
the next people to walk on the moon
think of the diversity
think of all the inclusion
i mean isn't this what gets you most
excited
perhaps we can set up a diversity equity
and inclusion uh seminar on the lunar
surface
hopefully they'll do that before they
worry about you know things like
figuring out how to build a sustainable
human colony i'm sure that'll be their
first priority get there and set up the
seminars right away
nasa has its priorities straight
which is why it's been bragging about
the diversity of its new space mission
all along leading to headlines like this
from a local abc affiliate in florida it
says nasa hopes artemis mission will
inspire diversity inclusion in future of
space
this is what they're primarily focused
on they would see
by the way unrelated i'm sure
um the artemis one launch failed
one of the engines wasn't working right
so space will have to wait a while
longer to be introduced to the
importance of diversity
now you might ask
what's wrong with
the powers that be focusing so much on
diversity
i mean am i against diversity am i
against a black person or a woman
walking on the moon is that what i'm
saying
no
here's the problem
you'll often hear that there's tons of
evidence proving that diverse groups of
people work better or more productive
more effective more efficient i'm sure
you've heard these claims before in fact
we heard that in the ap article i just
read one of the senior economists
formerly at the fed yale professor he
said that there's there's evidence
that diverse groups make better
decisions
now as always of course we're meant to
just end our inquiry there we've been
assured that the evidence exists
is there evidence yes there's evidence
we need not actually look at the
evidence for ourselves just just trust
that it's out there and some people have
seen it and those people assure us that
it validates all of their preconceived
notions conveniently that's just that's
just what it is i mean these people they
want there to be evidence
that what that their ideology is correct
and they say that there is evidence
they don't show us the evidence they
just say that it's there and that's all
you should need
but i'm a little more stubborn than that
so i do insist on seeing the evidence if
you can believe it and and um
what you find
if you look for the data supporting
these assertions about diversity is that
the data doesn't exist
it just doesn't
there's a woman named alice h eagley a
professor at northwestern university
she looked for the evidence too and
wrote an article for the conversation in
2016 with these findings and by the way
she actually has links to all the
studies which is a different strategy
from what you usually get
um but here's what she writes advocates
for diversity generally maintain that
the addition of women to corporate
boards enhances corporate financial
success and they hold the diversity in
task groups enhances their effectiveness
abundant findings have accumulated on
both of these questions more than 140
studies of corporate boards and more
than 100 studies of
socio-demographic diversity in task
groups
both sets of studies have produced mixed
outcomes some studies show positive
associations of diversity to those
outcomes and some show negative
association
social scientists use meta-analyses to
integrate such findings across the
relevant studies meta-analyses represent
all the available studies on a
particular topic by quantitatively
averaging their findings and also
examining differences in study's results
cherry picking is not allowed
taking into account all of the available
research on corporate boards and
diversity of task groups the net effects
are very close to to a null or zero
average
also economist studies that uh carefully
evaluate causal relations have typically
failed to find that women cause superior
corporate performance the most valid
conclusion at this point is that on
average diversity neither helps nor
harms these important outcomes
now this is the case even given the
enormous handicap that most studies
showing that diversity has a negative or
neutral impact will never see the light
of day
almost all the academics and social
scientists who set out to investigate
this question have a very particular
result in mind
which is a big problem
and if they don't get that result we
have to trust that they'll report their
findings honestly anyway but we
obviously know that we cannot trust that
and anyway this is all somewhat beside
the point
so
most diversity research
simply compares groups of people in a
professional environment and finds a way
to measure their productivity
you know so you've got a a diverse group
and then a less diverse group and then
you measure their productivity and
hopefully the researchers doing this
they want to be able to say that oh look
at that the diverse group is more
effective
and then it will just pronounce that
diversity is helpful or harmful based on
that measurement
when measured this way
and this is what in the article we just
read there when measured that way
diversity seems to be basically
irrelevant
but the real question is about the
impact of assembling a team
with diversity in mind to begin with
what happens when you recruit people
based on diversity quotas
and then put them together to accomplish
a task
now if everyone is hired based purely on
their skill and competence and it just
so happens that you end up with a
diverse team great
if you end up with a non-diverse team
that way that's fine too and if you take
two teams that are both put there
because of their skill and competence
and their qualifications and one is
diverse one is quote diverse and one is
less diverse probably they're going to
perform about the same that's what the
studies show because they're all there
for the same reason the the race and sex
is basically irrelevant
but what if more qualified people are
excluded
because they are not quote diverse
meaning because they're white or they're
male
that's the real question
considering this is how nearly every
major institution now operates
and recent evidence along with just
plain common sense tells us that
productivity and overall effectiveness
are definitely harmed when you hire
people based on attributes that have
nothing to do with their productivity
and effectiveness
okay when you when you need to
accomplish a task and you recruit people
and you base that recruitment on
anything other than their ability to
accomplish the task
then you're gonna end up with groups
that are less able to accomplish a task
than you would have if you had
prioritized accomplishing the task
that's the idea here
now in nasa's case this raises a
question about whether
the first black man and woman to walk on
the moon are in that position because
they happen to be the best for this
extremely dangerous and challenging job
if so great
or if they were selected first and
foremost because they checked the
desired identity boxes
did nasa recruit this team and then say
what do you know this works out great it
just so happens that we're going to have
the first uh woman and the first black
man on the moon is this is it just works
perfectly
or did they set out to engineer it that
way to begin with there's every reason
to believe the latter is the case indeed
there's good reason to believe that this
entire mission mostly exists just to put
people from those two identity
categories on the moon so that white men
will no longer be the only ones who have
ever done it
and if that is all true then this next
phase of space exploration suddenly
looks a lot less promising because space
is a brutal deadly cold desolate
unforgiving place if you go there with
anything less than the absolute best and
most qualified people you're inviting
disaster despite what nasa seems to
think space does not care about
diversity and inclusion and never will
but there's another problem a deeper
problem with this focus on diversity
which is which is especially underscored
when applied to space exploration but
also you know it applies across the
board
and it's that
diversity and inclusion
are quite hollow
small
petty concerns
they can't serve as the marching orders
for a civilization not a thriving one
anyway
they aren't important or significant
enough to hang our collective hopes on
nobody's ever been motivated to do great
things for the sake of diversity equity
and inclusion now there certainly were
civil rights pioneers in history who
achieved greatness for the cause of
justice and racial equality but that's
not what diversity and inclusion as we
know it
is about
in a modern context it means simply
checking identity boxes that's what it
means
and box checking does not lead to
greatness
certainly cannot propel us into the
unknown into deep space
can't take us anywhere really worth
going
because for that you need things like
faith courage intelligence skill
and all of those things have
increasingly
taken a back seat
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know the supreme court decision to
overturn roe is a huge albeit long
overdue step in the right direction but
there's still a long way to go to raid
our country of abortion we've still got
a long fight ahead of us many companies
are bowing to the woke mob by donating
to pro-choice causes and candidates or
even reimburse reimbursing their
employees travel so that they can you
know if they live and work in a pro-life
state they can travel to a pro-abortion
state and get an abortion and be back at
work on monday which is what's most
important to these companies obviously
well what if i told you that if you're
currently on a phone plan with one of
the major carriers you might be
supporting these companies and their
pro-abortion agenda with your monthly
phone bill don't let abortionists use
your money to fund policies you don't
believe in switch to charity mobile
instead charity mobile is a pro-life pro
family cell phone company that sends
five percent of your monthly plan price
to the pro-life charity of your choice
you don't have to compromise on values
or good phone service charity mobile
offers the latest 5g phones no device or
service contracts great nationwide
coverage and live customer service based
right here in the usa the fight for the
right to life continues and pro-life
causes need your support you can help by
simply switching your phone service to
charity mobile today call
three six six 1-877-474-3662 or chat
with them online at charitymobile.com
mention offer code walsh to redeem a
free cell phone offer that is
charitymobile.com mention code walsh
all right one other point about this
nasa thing and mainly this is just an
excuse to play a clip from camila harris
because you know what a fan i am of of
hers and uh especially i'm an admirer of
her eloquence and her insight and so
she before the mission failed before the
launch failed she uh had some some
thoughts about it and
it plays in exactly to what we were
talking about in the opening but let's
listen
i'm so proud
of what is happening in terms of our
space program and the leadership that
the united states is providing to the
world
the artemis program is is the beginning
of the next era
of what we have a history and a
tradition of doing
of providing vision and inspiring
innovation in a way that is going to
benefit all mankind and womankind and so
i'm very excited to be here
mankind and woman kind now never mind
that you can't define the word woman as
we know
the point is that you see the division
and this is the other thing that you get
from this uh this focus on diversity and
inclusion it's really it's really about
it's about of course it's always about
dividing by putting people into
different categories and different
little buckets and then treating them
differently depending on which bucket
they're in and you see that here too
because
um
you know apollo 11
according to camille harris
it didn't land on the moon for all of
humanity
when when uh you know the words the
fateful words one giant leap for mankind
according to her that just meant
men like literally men
and so now we need another mission for
womankind so we had we had the man
mission for mankind
even though of course
mankind means humanity it means everyone
and by the way if you have a problem
with
the term mankind because has the word
man in it
well
the word human also has the word man and
i got news for you
but that's irrelevant because it just me
it means everybody
and that's what it meant when apollo 11
landed on the moon
but now that's not no now we so we got
the mankind mission so that was the
mission for the boys and now we need now
we need the woman mission
and then there's also there's also a
black man because according to the you
know the identity
uh politics
gurus somehow when they when they talk
about sort of like men in general
especially in a derogative sense
uh in a derogatory sense they only ever
they mean white men of course
so this is not about this is what it's
it's about it's the missions to space
for different identity groups rather
than just for everyone and it used to be
that space exploration was about it was
about
increasing humanity's understanding
of the world of the universe
that's what that's why it was such a
uniting moment
for
the country anyway
but not anymore okay this is from the
hill it says republican worries of a
midterm flop are growing heading into
the critical post-labor day campaign
season with analysts who had previously
predicted massive gop gains shifting
their forecasts towards democrats rick
tyler republican strategist and analyst
said the environment looks not even
close to a red wave election year the
enthusiasm is just not there tyler said
last time republicans had a good year
they were six points ahead of the
generic poll now we're barely two points
ahead so it's definitely not going to
happen real clear politics averages the
polls measuring whether voters would
prefer republican or democratic control
of congress show the gop advantage
slipping from 4.8 points in late april
to less than a point as of friday
at around this point in 2010 when
republicans saw historic gains in
congress generic polls showed an
advantage of four to six points for the
gop
and so this is the this is the media
narrative is that republicans are losing
their grip on the midterms and that is
the media narrative this is of course
the narrative that they want
um
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
not true now when the media says
something
just because they said it doesn't mean
you could trust it obviously it also
doesn't automatically mean that it's not
true
and because there are times when the the
media narrative happens to line up with
reality and when that happens it's it's
purely incidental but uh this is one of
those incidental occasions i believe
where the media narrative lines up with
reality which is that which is that
republicans
um
you know you can decide how much you
trust polls but but this is what the
polls are showing this is also i don't
know this is kind of like totally
anecdotal this is the sense you sort of
get from people is that republicans are
losing the steam that we thought they
had leading into the midterms um all
indications right now are that the
promised and hoped for red wave looks
less likely than it did a few months ago
could still happen because things change
in a dime
but um and
nobody remembers anything from 24 hours
ago so any trend that exists 24 hours
ago could go away and reverse itself
because we all have the memories of
fruit flies but
but that's how it is right now
and i think the reason i agree with ben
shapiro's analysis of this which he
offered yesterday i basically agree that
republicans are are one of the problems
is that one of the big problems is that
republicans are not staying on message
they're losing focus
um
i think
part of the reason for that is
you know as things as the conversation
among republicans and on the right has
turned more to donald trump
uh with the fbi rate and everything and
there were a lot of conservatives
thought well this is this is what's
going to be the red people are going to
be motivated to go to the polls because
of this
the dems have really stepped in at this
time
but we have to remember is that
if the democrats thought and when i say
the democrats i'm including the fbi in
that
if they thought that it would hurt them
politically to do the raid
they wouldn't have done it i mean
they're only going to do what they think
will help them
and if they thought that talking about
donald trump a lot and making him the
subject making him the topic
right if making the election about him
if they thought that would hurt them
they wouldn't do it
but they do it because they've decided
that it helps them it's all they have
it is all they have like they want to
talk about donald trump because they get
they got nothing else
the last thing they want to do
is talk about what's actually happening
in the country right now and the issues
that really affect people on a
day-to-day basis i mean think
about what normal people
wake up every day worried about
you don't you don't have to
speculate about this if you're a normal
person and especially if you're a you
have a family you're a parent you have
kids you have a spouse what are the
kinds of things that you wake up is like
the first thing you worry about in the
morning you go to bed thinking about it
uh what are the kinds of things the
cliche about sitting around the kitchen
table but whether it's around your
kitchen table or someone else somewhere
else in the house what are the things
that you sit around talking about with
your spouse it's um
well it's it's finances
okay people are worried about their
finances
uh they're worried about their family's
safety
they're worried about their children's
future
their
heart broken by america's cultural
collapse it's continuing plunge into
insanity
these are the things that really trouble
people and for good reason and this is
what they're thinking about
this is what republicans should be
speaking to
that's how they win
and i would suggest
that you could see a direct correlation
when republicans are on message about
that stuff economy crime uh the you know
the grooming and indoctrination and
mutilation and drugging of children the
cultural uh decay like these kinds of
things
people live immersed in these issues
every day it's what affects them most
directly
it affects not affects their wall in
their bed cap but also you know it
speaks to the also you need to go beyond
that too the issues that speak to their
to their heart their deepest concerns
and that's what deals with like what's
going to happen to their kids what kind
of world are we leaving behind for their
kids when republicans are talking about
that i think you see in the polls that
they do well when they get away from
that
they start to trail off that's the
correlation i think we see
everything else is a distraction
republican politicians and candidates
who can't speak consistently and
compellingly to these kinds of issues
and who haven't shown an ability and
willingness to take action to fix it
should be disregarded really no
exceptions
there are we know there are plenty of
republicans who have been stuck in a
1990s mentality for a long time
these are like the establishment
republicans have been stuck they still
think it's 1995.
and they're useless
but same goes for republicans who are
stuck in 2016.
also that's going to make you useless
because we live in a different world now
and it's changing every day and not for
the better
why republicans need to be dialed in and
focused on that
um when something relevant happens with
donald trump well of course you talk
about it he gets raided by the fbi that
is uh that is outrageous and it's
something that should be discussed
but
you can't make that the focus the more
that's the focus then we're not talking
about all these other things over here
that the democrats don't want you to
talk about
the fact that communities all across the
country are being ravaged by crime and
nothing is being done to stop it
they don't want to talk about that it's
the last thing they want to talk about
oh it's very clear they don't want to
talk about the trans agenda and how
that's affecting kids i mean they so
badly don't want to talk about it that
they will accuse you of being a
terrorist if you do talk about it that's
how desperate they are to not talk about
it which is exactly why we should be
well you have to do
strategically
think about the things that your
opponent doesn't want to talk about
and talk about those real simple
strategy
if there's a subject that your opponent
really really wants to discuss
that's probably what you should
stay away from as much as you can or
spend a second on it and move on to the
next thing
all right john fetterman is uh
letting his racist flag
fly now i will give him credit here i i
really am impressed by this actually
that this is a take a 30 second clip
and he is able to string together
um 30 seconds worth
of you know sentences and it is it's
basically coherent so i'll give them
that but that's the most i can say about
this let's listen
in my own state they are going to pass
attempt to pass a constitutional
amendment making sure that universal
voting id for every time you vote not
just when you sign up to vote but every
time you vote because they understand
that at any given time there's tens of
thousands of pennsylvanians who
typically typically are on the uh or on
the the poorer side and and are people
of color that are less likely to have
their id at any one given time
oh yeah well you know black people
they're they're not they don't know how
to get id's so it's that old
canard again
this is this is not even this is not
this is something worse than bigotry of
low expectations
you know because when you
say that a certain group of people don't
know how to get photo ids that's that's
that's worse than loic that's just no
expectations whatsoever
and it is of course not even close to
true
well you know black people are less
likely to have ids what
first of all once
again if you are an adult
a functioning adult
in modern society
um so you're not homeless but like
outside of the homeless population
if you're an adult modern society
you you must have some kind of photo id
because you can't do anything without it
what what you can't rent
where do you live you can't rent an
apartment you certainly can't buy a
house um you can't get a credit card you
can't you can't do anything
you can't get a job you cannot do
anything without a photo id
so
if you refuse to get a photo id then
you've handicapped yourself not just
with voting but with everything in life
and there's no reason to handicap
yourself that way because getting a
photo id is enormously easy anyone can
do it
you know when you go to the dmv they
they make it very easy it's tedious
okay and it's annoying but they make it
very easy
so that you know anyone can do it it
doesn't matter who you are
you don't have to be some kind of like
you don't have to have a
be an expert
who who exactly i'm not sure i've ever
met
an adult that that does not have a photo
id at all and has never had one
who who are these adults
again outside of the homeless population
even them probably many of them have one
at least at one point had one
so i'm not sure i've met an adult who
doesn't have a photo id
i would like to meet an adult like that
just so i could talk to them i have so
many questions why don't you have one
how do you function
uh is like is this a choice why this
must be a choice that you're making why
is that a choice i mean maybe if you
want to live off the grid completely
no photo id burn your social security
card go go live in a hut in the woods i
mean like that's
that's an appealing option but outside
of that
this is one of the most this is one of
the most the most ridiculous straw men
that you hear from the left and i know
that's saying quite a lot
acting as though it is some great burden
to go get a photo
id even though one is required for
everything else and even though as we
know as as we know they they had no
problem requiring vaccine cards and all
the rest of it
so they can require you to go and inject
something into your body
and take a card and carry that around
with you
but going to get a photo id is a
is a burden that is too cumbersome for
people to carry
or not people they say specifically uh
too cumbersome for black people to carry
they say
which it's it's hard to think of
something more degrading insulting
and paternalistic than that
and also again completely false
all right
you know we are just months away from
the salem witch trials i would say this
is from people magazine um
sydney sweeney is she's an
actress i think she's an actress she's
facing backlash over photos from a
recent family function
um after throwing a surprise hoedown
themed party in idaho for her mom's 60th
birthday the current emmy award nominee
responded to online criticism of a photo
that shows one relative wearing a blue
lives matter t-shirt her brother trent
sweeney also shared photos that showed
guests wearing parody maga hats printed
with make 60 great again
and uh sweeney so there was a apparently
a big backlash against this big enough
that she responded to it she said you
guys this is wild an innocent
celebration for my mom's milestone 60th
birthday has turned into an absurd
political statement which was not the
intention please stop making assumptions
she was met with criticism further
criticism in the replies to that post
someone wrote then you should have
selected other pictures to post that
wouldn't be left up to interpretation in
this manner lesson learned for you i
assume others came to her defense and uh
but generally this was what the the fans
were coming after for now
this this is ridiculous for many reasons
but
apparently i'm learning from this
article
this actress is uh in the show euphoria
and she's been some other shows too but
that's primarily what she stars in
which
i've never seen the show i don't claim
to know a lot about it
but i think it's safe to say that
if somebody was uh you know deeply
conservative with conservative values
they're not gonna start in that show of
all shows
so
she she she would seem to be pretty safe
you don't have to worry she's not she's
not one of those uh right-wing witches
that you do have to find and burn at the
stake she's not one of them
but even being
indirectly associated with things that
aren't really conservative or
ideological but they but that themselves
can be associated with conservative
people so you've got multiple degrees of
separation
but even that
very indirect circuitous path
um to connecting with conservatives even
that is unacceptable
and she has to you know issue
clarifications everything now she hasn't
issued an apology yet
or disowned her family
rebuked her own family i i think would
probably wait a couple days for that if
the outrage doesn't die down in a couple
of days we'll see where she is but i
would not be that's usually
the uh trajectory of these kinds of
things
staying in the the world of um
you know of uh of media and uh and that
sort of thing olivia rodrigo who's
the pop star who's sang about getting
her uh driver's license or her learner's
permit or whatever it was
she performed with a billy joel
a couple of days ago
and variety put this clip from the
performance
out on twitter and i you know they put
it out in a positive way like oh listen
to this great performance
um
but i don't know listen to it for
yourself here it is
[Music]
the greatest thing
can we go can we get a screenshot of
just the very end there because you see
billy joel
stare i didn't notice it the first time
i watched this clip i think because i
did i actually it's the first time i
watched the clip the whole way through
it's only about 15 seconds
it i i it's too
like it's really difficult to watch it's
so embarrassing there's just something
about someone
someone singing badly that is is for
some reason it's so so difficult not
just because it hurts your ears but
because it's so embarrassing for them
uh but you can see billy joel in the
background he's looking at her like what
the hell is this what am i doing here
who is this person you've got this guy's
in his 70s he has no idea olivia
rodriguez i think she's a she's she's a
pop star whose
career began on tick tock i believe
right and so
she's only a pop star because she would
dance on tick tock and then that was her
and then the some record label came
along and said oh yeah we're going to
make you a pop star
because that's how it works now of
course it's worked that way for a long
time we'll just take some we don't have
any
ability whatsoever no musical ability
but it used to be that
i mean there was a time i mean
pop music has for a long time been
vacuous and and and bad
and um it's been a long time since
in general pop musicians were actual
musicians so they have no musical
ability
but it keeps getting worse because i
think there was a time at least when
they could do something
so you go back far enough and anyone who
is a famous musician it's because they
could play music they could write music
they could just produce music right and
it was all them
and then that went away
and of course they're not writing their
own music anymore
but at least they could they basically
had pretty good voices they could sing
and they could dance and so those are
those are skills they had got that going
for them
and now we're at a point where
you don't have to be able to do any of
that
to be to be a
i think she just won a grammy to a
grammy award-winning
millionaire pop star
cannot sing cannot dance can't do
anything
and yet she's on stage with billy joel
who was clearly regretting all of his
life choices i wanted to mention this
too this is interesting a story
from msn it says a school district in
southwest missouri is bringing back a
measure it last resorted to over two
decades ago to address disciplinary
problems
that is spanking students
classes started monday for the 1900
students in classville
um r-4 school district about an hour
west of branson and some 15 miles from
the arkansas border during open house
families were notified that the school
board had adopted a policy in june
allowing physical force as a method of
correcting student behavior
parents were handed forms to specify
whether they authorized the school to
use a paddle on their child
formerly known as corporal punishment
the disciplinary measure usually
involves spank striking students on the
buttocks with a wooden paddle
in casseville staff members will employ
reasonable physical force without a
chance of bodily injury or harm in the
presence of a witness this is according
to the new policy
now what exactly constitutes reasonable
physical force is unclear but that's
what they're going to do now
this is interesting to me because it
kind of again highlights
some of the fundamental problems with
the school system the public school
system
it's true
that there's a total lack of discipline
in the school system
kids don't respect their teachers or the
administrators
they don't care about the punishments
suspension in particular is a is a
really i think this is where the
paddling idea originally came from is
that they were looking for
another form of punishment instead of
suspension
and that makes sense in a certain way
because suspension suspension is a is a
particularly stupid form of punishment
because the kinds of kids who get
suspended
are also the kinds of kids who love
nothing more than to stay home from
school
and they're likely to be the kinds of
kids whose parents aren't going to hold
them accountable at home so by
suspending them you're not really
accomplishing anything suspension only
works as a disciplinary tool if the
child being suspended number one wants
to come to school and so you're taking
something away from him that he wants
and two
has parents who will react with
appropriately severe
you know with appropriate severity to
their child being suspended in the first
place
so if you need both of those criteria to
be met in order for the suspension to
work as a punishment
but usually
um neither of the criteria are met
so what are you left with
they don't really expel kids anymore
um unless they're found guilty of
misgendering in which case we make you
know then you can toss them out
there's detention but that only goes so
far and uh what if a kid refuses to show
up to detention what do you do
this is the kind of hopeless
situation that lots of teachers and
administrators are in it there's like
there's nothing they can do the kids are
not listening
they don't care they have no respect
um they have no you know they haven't
been raised to respect their elders or
anything like that so just what are you
supposed to do with them
and it's what makes you think well maybe
it's time to introduce corporal
punishment as another option
but then here
here comes another complication because
if i'm a parent sending my kid to public
school
in the year 2022
i am not going to be okay with paddling
because there's no way in hell that i
trust the teachers or administrators to
dole out a punishment like that
appropriately or responsibly i just
don't trust them
and so when you're using physical force
in that way and you're authorizing
another adult a stranger you have to
really trust there's been a lot of trust
there
but i'm not going to have that kind of
trust
in any of the adults working in the
school system right now i just don't
trust you
so no stranger especially not one in
public schools laying a hand on my kid i
don't trust them i don't trust any adult
with that especially not government
workers in a government in the
government school system
yeah i'm not gonna i'm not gonna entrust
government employees
to
physically punish my child no this is
the conundrum then
that you deal with
the lacks discipline doesn't work
but harsher discipline requires a
certain amount of trust between school
and parent and that trust doesn't exist
and largely that's the fault of the
schools
because they've destroyed all that trust
so what's the answer
well i'll tell you what the answer is
get your kid out of the public school
system that's the answer
all right let's get to the comment
section
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
oh by the way um i uh i'm going to get
the comments in a section but in a
second but i do have to mention this
because we were just talking about
horrible um
you know pop music and all of that
and i i had this also on the docket to
mention because i can't fail to mention
it
um taylor swift has a new uh album
coming out that she just and i think she
announced it at the vmas and so it's
really exciting it's a it's an album
called midnight
and i think the album the idea is that
these are all songs that she wrote in
the middle of the night or something
like that
and now she
most of her music especially recent
music is really really bad
you give her credit though because she
does actually write her own music and
she can basically sing so she's got that
going for her at least
that she's also a terrible writer at the
same time so this is her instagram post
announcing the new album
this is what she wrote
and this is like um
middle school
creative writing level stuff here okay
we lie awake in love and in fear in
turmoil and in tears
we stare at walls and drink until they
speak back
we twist in our self-made cages and pray
that we aren't right this minute about
to make some fateful life-altering
mistake
this is a collection of museum what this
is a collection of music written in the
middle of the night a journey through
terrors and sweet dreams the floors we
pace and the demons we face
for all of those who have tossed and
turned and decided to keep the lanterns
lit and go searching
hoping that just maybe
when the clock strikes 12
we'll meet ourselves
i guess this is what passes for poetry
these days it's better than amanda
gorman at least
but all i could say is first of all
what's this we stuff speak for yourself
so she's talking about this as if this
is a common you know we've all we've all
been through this you're lying awake at
night
drinking so much that so that the walls
are talking to you
i've never had that experience i don't
think that's a is that a universal human
experience i've never been through that
before
praying that you don't make a fateful
life-altering mistake what the hell are
you doing at night
now i'm kind of interested in actually
listening to the album i i this is
taking a very dark turn all right lisa
says matt your segment about
homelessness was not correct not all
homeless or drug addicts actually less
than 40 percent abuse drugs
there are a lot of comments uh in this
vein taking me to task because i said
that in the homeless population almost
all of them are homeless because they
are drug addicts and or have serious
mental illnesses
and there were few people that were
upset by that and and i did hear this
statistic quoted a few times
only forty percent are sure
i don't know where you're getting that
information
i'll believe that you got it from
somewhere maybe there's some kind of
study or something that was done i i
believe it i don't buy it though that's
it come on that's it's just it
you have to be able to use your common
sense sometimes
is that really what you think less than
half of homeless people are abusing
drugs
have you been
i mean go
anywhere where there are homeless people
and what you're saying is
clearly just your claim evaporates
in the face of reality
go anywhere where there are homeless
people and walk around and what you see
drug abuse and mental illness everywhere
now it may not be literally everyone
there may be a few exceptions here and
there
but that is largely what leads a person
to end up sleeping on the street you
know on on a cardboard mattress that's
what largely will and will will lead
someone to that point
it's not
an insult that's not anything it's
simply the reality
and it's important to
confront that and acknowledge that
because if you want to actually do
something about the homeless problem you
have to be able to
understand why the homeless problem
exists in the first place what's causing
it
all right
jay star says matt said that the podcast
group apologizing over ben shapiro
showing up was the most pathetic apology
he'd ever seen i'd say that john cena an
american groveling to china in chinese
over calling taiwan a country was even
worse that was one of the most pitiful
emasculating things i've seen i forgot
about that one that might
it's a competition they're both in the
top five
um maybe i forgot about the john cena
one because he wasn't speaking in
english it wasn't you know you couldn't
tell exactly what he was saying but um
yeah that's certainly that's in like
that's
that's in the running we must uh admit
ninja squirrel says this whole hotel
thing they tried that already in
amarillo texas in less than 72 hours
there was a number of fires so this is
they tried opening up the hotel rooms
empty hotel rooms to homeless people and
this is what ninja squirrel and this is
a source you can trust this is what he
says happen in less than 72 hours there
was a number of fires four stabbings and
one shooting seven accounts of rape etc
three whole floors were ruined due to
vandalism not counting the fires mind
you to such an extreme that the entire
hotel was forced to close forever
am i saying that los angeles can do
better
um definitely i'm willing to bet money
on the fact that los angeles can do it
in under 24 hours
yeah this is los angeles would not be
the first uh city to try this there are
other cities that have done similar
things and it always ended disaster and
and and also going back to the first
comment and anyone else who took
exception to me saying that you know
homeless people by and large drug
addicted mentally ill
um unstable
you you say that you you uh that's not
true that's not fair oh really but like
what
if that's the case you know and if you
don't believe that then uh okay you've
got two hotels to choose from
in
one
your entire floor is going to be
comprised of homeless people who have
been given those rooms
and in the other if they're all paying
customers which one are you choosing
which one are you going to go to
is it just a fl
flip the coin doesn't matter to you
no you know that you would not feel safe
on the floor of homeless people because
so many of them are drug addicts and
mentally ill and unstable prone to
violence all of these
things um
madd says my husband's a corrections
officer in utah which doesn't have near
the problem of homelessness that's that
california does but he deals with more
homeless and mentally ill people than
actual criminals there's a large group
that just rotates in and out of jail
they get to sleep in a warm bed and get
food then two weeks later they let out
most county jails are treated as mental
institutions and it does not help the
homeless people in the slightest yep
just another nothing but band-aids
that's all we're doing with the homeless
problem and in every pretty much every
other problem in society a bunch of
band-aid solutions because we don't want
to get to the core of it you don't want
to get to the root of it because we
can't even talk about the root of the
problem because as soon as you do that
people start getting offended for some
reason
john williams says seriously matt
speaking for many on behalf of the sweet
baby gang we missed the flannel shirts
the blazers look fine but perhaps you
could switch back and forth just saying
grenade away says wow matt you've got a
new studio and now you wear blazers
every day so i guess you sold
out that's what makes me sell up man
you've got you you've got a low bar
for selling out
you've got me in a pretty tight box here
just wearing slightly nicer clothing
and doing a show that's not in front of
a sheet
is selling out
um well then i guess i'll sell it what
can i say
well if you can believe it which uh of
course you can because i've been the
butt end of a sick joke for weeks now
the walrus destined for my possession is
still being withheld and it was
announced yesterday that ben who had
access to my walrus before me
released little stuffed walruses
even held up the wrong one yesterday
because uh he has so many walruses he's
like drowning in walruses
while i have none
that's a mistake i'm not sure i'll ever
ha i'll ever have the luxury to make and
now not only has he withheld my walrus
from me but his fans are buying
their walruses before you which is
unacceptable
this is all getting very weird so go to
dailywire.com shop or click the link in
the description to get these adorable
cuddly companions to my book johnny
walrus which you can also get by the way
and that also makes a perfect gift for
any child or sweet baby they actually
did a great job with this this is really
high quality walrus material rather than
buying another stuffed animal for your
kids from woke companies that hate your
values buy these walruses instead my
kids will really enjoy this and i'm sure
your kids will too my kids would most
enjoy the the big giant walrus which i
still have not been given but uh this
will be the consolation prize i suppose
head over to dailywire.com shop to get
yours now
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
much of what passes for modern
journalism today consists of taking some
obvious feature of physical reality and
declaring that it's a myth
this claim is then supported with a
series of assertions
along with frantic assurances that
there's at least one study out there
somewhere that supports whatever they're
asserting we discussed an egregious
example of this last week with the
scientific americans documentary series
seeking to debunk
the concept of the sex binary
and this week the new york times has
gotten in on the action with this op-ed
titled maternal instinct is a myth that
men created
now once again you see
um
the the thing that you always thought
existed
you've always known existed and you've
witnessed yourself and maybe experienced
yourself and which all of human society
has believed in and professed and bore
witness to
is a myth
not only that but it's a myth very
recently invented by patriarchal men
sometime around the dawn of the
industrial revolution
this is the claim that the writer
chelsea conneboy a journalist
specializing in health it says in her
bio wants you to believe
the article itself is lengthy and takes
many irrelevant detours into anecdotes
about women who suffer from postpartum
depression
she talks about a commercial that she
saw once at one point she cites a
stand-up special by a comedian named ali
wong like this is all evidence that she
uh marshalls to prove her point there's
a lot of fat to trim from the bone but
um
i think this portion here which i'll
read to you captures the essence of her
argument so this is what she writes
the notion that the selflessness and
tenderness babies require is uniquely
ingrained in the biology of women ready
to go at the flip of a switch is a
relatively modern and pernicious one it
was constructed over decades by men
selling an image of what a mother should
be diverting our attention from what she
actually is and calling it science it
keeps us from talking about what it
really means to become a parent and it
has emboldened policymakers in the
united states generation after
generation to refuse new parents and
especially mothers the support they need
today many proclaim that motherhood is
neither duty nor destiny that a woman is
not left unfulfilled or incomplete
without children but even as i write
these words i doubt them do we
collectively believe that maternal
instinct is still frequently invoked in
science writing parenting advice and
common conversation and whether we call
maternal instinct by its name or not its
influences everywhere belief in maternal
instinct and the deterministic value of
mother love has fueled pro-family
conservative politicians for decades
oh god forbid
those pro-family politicians you know
a uh a sinister bunt bunch and we get to
the substance of the argument there such
as it is um which i think can be handled
pretty quickly
first of all
whether maternal instinct exists or not
and it does we'll get that in a second
um the idea certainly is not modern you
can read ancient writings from across
the world including the bible and text
even older than that and find beautiful
homages written to to uh to s the
special bond between a mother and a
child
like every
ancient civilization has noticed this
and remarked upon it
not just remarked upon it but
built their civilizations with that in
mind
if there's anything unique about our
view of the subject
it's the opposite of what the author
claims only in the modern industrialized
west will even think to question whether
a mother has a special bond with and
duty to her own child
this is not even a subject of discussion
in other cultures nor was it through
history because the answer was so
obvious
maternal instinct was self-evident to
our ancestors
and like so many of their insights this
one has only been confirmed and
validated by modern science even if the
new york times would like to claim
otherwise
there was an article written in this
smithsonian magazine in 2021 titled the
new science of motherhood and it goes
into great detail about the biological
and neurological changes a woman goes
through when she becomes a mother
which serves to bond her even closer to
her child this stuff has been measured
you can see it
in fact the new york times itself the
new york times itself in 2008 published
an article with the headline
maternal instinct is wired into the
brain
it reports the results of one of the
many dozens of other scientific studies
showing how a mother's brain is
miraculously
wired to connect with her own child
reading from the article says tokyo
researchers use functional magnetic
resonancing imaging mri to study the
brain patterns of 13 mothers each of
whom had an infant about 16 months old
first the scientists videotaped the
mother smiling at their rather
videotaped a baby smiling at their
mothers during playtime
then the women left the room and the
infants were videotaped crying and
reaching for their mothers to come back
all of the babies were dressed in the
same blue shirt for the video shoot mri
scans were taken as each mother watched
videos of the babies including her own
with the sound off when a woman saw
images of her own child smiling or upset
her brain patterns were markedly
different than when she watched the
other children there was a particularly
pronounced change in brain activity when
a mother was shown images of her child
in distress the scan suggests the
particular circuits in the brain are
activated when a mother distinguishes
the smiles and cries of her own baby
from those of other infants the fact
that a woman responds more strongly to a
child's crying than to smiling seems to
be biologically meaningful in terms of
adaptation to specific demands
associated with successful infant care
the study authors noted
but
the maternal instinct doesn't just kick
in when a woman actually has a baby i
mean lots of things do happen and a
mother's brain is wired a certain way
and uh there are hormonal changes and
all these things
but girls from a young age are much more
inclined on average long before they
have kids of their own they're still
much more inclined on average to exhibit
maternal traits there's a reason why
girls play with baby dolls that's what
playing with a baby doll is all about i
mean think about you you've got little
girls who are
my daughter's two years old she's
already pretending to be a mother this
is what she loves to do more than
anything in the world it's to carry her
baby dolls around
now sure there are some boys who might
show an interest in baby dolls also but
they're the exception
nearly all parents on earth and who have
ever lived on earth have noticed in
their daughters an inclination towards
these sorts of things
the left wants us to doubt what we've
all seen what we all know to be true
and all they can give us to justify the
doubt are anecdotes about exceptions to
the rule and yet at the same time these
very same people validate what they
claim are unfair stereotypes by in the
next breath insisting that a boy who
shows maternalistic traits is probably
actually a girl
they can't get their own story straight
so i couldn't take them seriously even
if i wanted to and i don't
also we haven't taken into account the
animal kingdom where the females of any
given species are not only on average
the most likely to be primary or sole
caretakers of the young but also where
even among animals
mothers are often observed sacrificing
themselves to protect their young
how do we explain that
are chickens and polar bears and
elephants also subject to social
conditioning and political pressure
have they been manipulated by dastardly
conservative politicians
now of course human beings are different
from chickens and polar bears and
elephants in that we are self-aware and
we're capable of making moral choices
and this is the one possible criticism
of maternal instinct as it relates to
humans that i would entertain
is that you might argue that calling a
human mother's love and devotion to her
child an instinct
diminishes it
you know when a mother rushes into a
burning building to rescue her child
um it's not just instinct it is she's
making a choice she's making a heroic
choice
and we should acknowledge that she's not
merely obeying her biology like some
kind of
machine but all that means is that human
mothers have a maternal instinct along
with
something far more powerful
which is a soul a mind
capable of making these kinds of choices
the writer of this article is aware of
that actually and that's really her
point
she wants women
to use their higher faculties
to reject their maternal instinct
override it
turn it against itself
and deny everything that makes them
special and unique
many women in our culture have done
exactly this tragically violently
rejecting their motherly vocation
through abortion
increasingly there are women who reject
womanhood entirely and have doctors cut
out their female reproductive organs so
they can live as some bizarre mutilated
approximation of a man
and this is what the writer ultimately
wants
and what the left wants generally
which is why when they deny
that things are a certain way
what they really mean
is that they think that things ought not
be that way
this is one of the most important things
understand about the left
when they look at physical reality and
they say oh no it's not like that
no they know that it is like that what
they're saying is it shouldn't be
this is something we should destroy to
the best of our ability
they want us to live as if a certain
reality is not the reality
maternal instinct exists
but it shouldn't i mean that's chelsea
conneboy's real point
and it's why she is today finally
canceled and that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hopefully you have
become a member by now if you haven't
make sure you do that so you can join us
for the rest of the show otherwise we
will see you tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you